des chants des rires et des sourires
l'après midi est animée à l'ehpad de
saint louis afin d'apporter un peu de
joie à nos gramounes
le conseil départemental des jeunes
ayant organisé une journée
intergénérationnelle
les personnes âgées parce qu'ils passent
en dernier
tribunal
ça court puisque déjà allé parlant
beaucoup de choses un moment d'échangés
de partages touchant entre ces deux
générations
a380 elle a une folle envie de s'éclater
pouvoir j'aime me fait plaisir de voir
toutes ces jeunes un danger à nous mêmes
qu'on dit mouloud et puis danger parce
que notre eau dont j'ai d'abord en fait
pas tellement en danger plutôt plus de
travail et mia majeurs wendel a amusé
les rois et là j'avais de la part
payante
au programme de cet après midi des jeux
de société du coloriage une chorale
les aussi un atelier bien-être animée
par les jeunes dans une ambiance détente
à la réunion le nombre de personnes
dépendantes ne cesse d'augmenter et
pourrait atteindre les 26 1700 personnes
en 2030 selon l'insee le département
finance en partie les établissements
d'hébergement pour les personnes âgées
dépendantes
rappelons que la collectivité est le
chef de file de l'action sociale et à
consacrer en 2015 plus de 110 millions
d'euros dans les dispositifs en faveur
des personnes âgées
ça apporte un bien fou aux résidents ils
sont contents ils peuvent échanger sur
ce qu'ils ont vécu sur le passé mais en
même temps il bat ça leur apporte un peu
de jeunesse un peu de jus un peu de goût
de vie c'est génial c'est génial donc en
même temps c'est une leçon de vie aussi
pour les jeunes
donc c'est important c'est important
qu'ils aient cette envie va devenir à la
rencontre de nos g
une prise de conscience pour ces jeunes
qui souhaitent renouveler cette action
afin d'apporter un peu plus de joie à
nos gramounes
voilà
voit que les personnes souvent incertain
sont abandonnés ne sent pas de visite
hélas pour eux venir passer à madrid il
voit les versants c'est bien une journée
intergénérationnelle réussi en attendant
la prochaine action du conseil
départemental des jeunes l'après midi se
conclue autour d'un goûter toujours
rythme